hello everybody my name is markiplier
and I'm so angry
oh no I broke this guy's poor house
sorry I was actually looking around for
so long that I actually had to for the
first time look up what I was supposed
to do and when I saw that this is what
you were supposed to do
I felt so bad that I did nothing about
him started recording the episodes so
here we go
artifact of unknown origin consists of a
very durable material even strong
mechanical or chemical action cannot
damage the structure of the object
presumably a droid of fact about 9,000
years not over okay for further
excavation requires better equipment
okay so we're wandering around outside
now without any oil I still don't have
any oil excavation sector F I wish I
could read that sign but it's too damn
dark got some weird devices over here
whispers in the darkness always a good
sign is this a reaper artifact of some
sort is this indoctrination that's
happening to me
I have no oil I'm not going to be able
to do anything l oh I see a giant thing
can I pick this up I can you know for an
odd custom campaign I think I said
before but there's a lot of custom stuff
in this and I haven't seen it anything
else so let's find out what's upstairs
shall we I think we shall hello
okey picked up a key oh excuse me sir
you seem to have been dragged away in a
expeditious fashion are you alright
could I follow you no I cannot okay wish
I had a lantern but oh well I will just
make do without it's not bad to have a
game that rat makes forces you to save
up but I do hate being out of it in the
darkness okay there's got to be
something else down here correct hello
hello wait what is this wait a minute is
it just a walled in area here is there
actually something to this it's like a
door here that I can't go in window
there and then there's a strange device
in the chair I through to get in here
so something actually hears it just all
walled in strange place to build a house
I guess but that's all there is all
right this weird whispery thingy okay
either way it doesn't matter I found a
key I can go to a next-door correct
correct
okay let's see what awaits me in this
room of darkness Oh lightness yay it's
not darkness an actual happy fun room
there's a bed so it's definitely a happy
fun room mm-hmm
I'm troubled with silence for several
days there is no information from other
archaeological sites but there are other
more frightening incidents yesterday I
was surprised to find this someone
locked the back door to the security
post without any explanation or warning
we're like in a cage exit to the
stairwell is blocked in elevators broke
I am sure we'll get an explanation of
the situation soon professor cata
nope you're dead all your friends are
dead everyone you know is dead and even
you dead and I found oil thankfully
during excavation sector F found
fragments Phoenicians Sumerian pottery
similar finds of ancient civilization
they were found in the region excavation
submergent aint Rock buried conical
objects eight branches formed with
blades not like Sumerian Egyptian or
other landmark what are we dealing with
aliens aliens man it's the only
explanation
alrighty I'm assuming that I can use
this hammer to break the locking hi
Wolfie I guess doggy whatever the hell
that was
I have no idea it doesn't matter it
don't matter you're in the back yo your
your belts are squished down in the seat
you'll never find him if anyone knows
when I'm whew alright do they keep that
yes
I kept the hammer I always like it when
I keep the stuff that I bring
or keep the stuff that I used to break
other things and more oil thank garsh
okay but I'm still gonna be wandering
around in the dark for a bit because I
want to conserve and I'm not like if I
need it at certain points I'll pull it
out I'll whip it out for you but oh hey
it's another dead body
oh this one's actually a grunt surprise
they put a grunt here okay okay
that's normal this is normal Kurt chunk
what did that do there what why high
overseer himself instructed us to
experience this mechanism the general
principle of this device is not too
clear to me there's no reason to worry
electric targets are pretty harmless for
ordinary people but I'm anything but
ordinary right ow
as if he's happy as if he's a bazooka
zap zow okay so I'm not gonna use these
to try to destroy a monster
I hope okay that one's broken Hamas is
gonna get up I know he is don't you
can't fool me I know he's gonna get up
okay I need to use this to get into you
it's weird that that's the lockpick they
can the moon those are some big
footprints that's some big-ass
footprints okay nope no nope no way
ah no no no no no no no all right fine
- god damn it you suck you suck game
game maker I swear to god I'm gonna stab
you with a surgical needle in the
eyeball okay yeah that's what I thought
oh crap
you know what you know what you know
what you know what you know what [ __ ]
yeah you wanna walk through the
electricity you [ __ ] bring it on
yeah get yeah that that happened I think
you just burst into pieces yeah yeah
yeah what up what up what up what did I
get
living sector C all year food yeah I'm
gonna yeah yeah
I shouldn't be bragging just cuz there
was a conveniently placed thing to
destroy a monster specifically designed
to destroy a monster I should not be
bragging don't need a lantern here we're
perfectly fine I'm gonna meet mister
fiery head he's just a little angry
that's why he's burning at the seams
yeah hi buddy hi how you doing doing
good good good to see you how's the
family wife kids good okay we're getting
out here oh thank you
what did he do Oh it's booze man bye bye
bye bye boat man I don't like mousse man
I'm a surprise you know custom stories
don't use mousse man that often even
though he is much scarier to me than the
grunt like mousse man is just terrifying
to me maybe that's why because he's not
used all that much I supposed to be
calling a moose band is a bit derogatory
anybody down there you want a bucket
whoosh I jump down there yeah squeeze
down there I'm too fat okay alrighty
then
what is I that spider Harley Wow okay
well done I haven't seen many people try
to use shadows
okay I'm burning a lot of oil but it's a
lot of dark places I can't help it I'm
at well I don't have much left hey why
won't you open hello can I use a hammer
on you no okay
ah I'm a bit nervous if this press the
situation I am is getting more
precarious and out Thank You more
tinderboxes at least they're giving me
plenty of tinderboxes that's all I can
really ask for in this nightmare of a
place iron key yay my favorite band what
the hell is that the hell I've never
heard a sound like that before alright
then can I get out please all right
let's just keep moving go to hell
whatever you were and let me carry on
with my life
I don't want to deal with your bowl not
that easy to break how about with an
iron key what BAM no really can I use
this out of this way maybe hang on them
maybe I'm not getting it right on there
nope okay it's not it's a no-go key here
nope okay
hi how are you doing you don't sound too
good block from the other side hello can
you do anything okay
man is a key gonna do any good says to
Lowery's lab this is Lowery's lab
finally damn it
damn time give us some privacy in here
alrighty sort of switch that all the way
down yeah okay what did that do okay so
I need to do some similar lab stuff that
I've done before I need to extract some
craft smash it real good what is that
call gulag I don't know yeah what does
that say sulfuric acid cool so what do I
do with this is this actually something
because this is looks pretty important
do I need this this looks important I'm
gonna keep this here and not throw it
randomly in a strange direction in anger
like I do with most of the things that I
have all right so those ever I can't
talk there's some actual science
materials the latest experiments were a
success it seems that I have derived a
new formula acid improved formula is
able to effectively dissolve many metals
mixture obtained in the first booth
dissolves only certain metals but after
reheating properties of the acid is
incredibly improved I hope this is
exactly what Henry asked for their
studies well technically I could take
this sulfuric acid and dissolve that
metal or at least degrade the metal lock
couldn't I maybe just a little bit you
don't think possibly nah nah that'd be
too easy
alrighty then so what am i doing I don't
even know
that's lever opened something let's just
find out what it was what did that lever
open block from the other side
goody-goody gumdrops
I don't know I don't know oh go home ow
my eye something just went in my eye
what am i doing what are you on why
can't I open anything why is every
single door locked what am I missing
why am I so dumb why do I ask so many
questions
when there's no one here to answer them
I don't know and I don't care I am an
enigma perpetually wandering the halls
screaming where's the blacksmith oh
maybe the chemicals are already in here
oh okay
hang on no no don't be like that oh I
see you glowing there you go
maybe yeah maybe everything's all ready
in here man come on come on there we go
Oh ba ba ba yes all right we got
something cool beans
[Music]
okay-y let's close this door hahaha why
okay we need to reheat it that's what
they said oh don't be like that there we
go okay
then we heat it up bubbly bubbly bubbly
bubbly we get it nice and hot we got
some super acid sweet Lowry's acid got
it
scram let's get out of here what was
that weird door sound something that I
need to know about are you just gonna
keep that a secret from me until you
jump out at me
probably other fancy amazing did that
really use all the acid though home
break door which door which door are you
speaking of alright if you say so
how about the one that was brought from
the other side I cannot move at all with
this thing the door is quite sturdy
okey-dokey
how about this one and why do all these
sledgehammers have blood on them okay
smash yeah yeah how you like me now try
you damn it didn't work just gonna just
oh damn it oh I fudged up I fudged up I
wasn't paying attention at all that's
okay I can smash this door too oh there
we go
got that one try them all let's try them
all smash okay not that one came through
that one BAM nope that's not gonna work
hang on Oh me nope it's all goofed up
alright anymore anymore anymore anymore
boom nope okay why was one door quite
sturdy be the others I don't know but
let's just carry on we got one door open
that means we can move forward I don't
think I want to
why are we here tours Oh got a nice
lovely tours Oh in oil gigantic
cockroach Jesus yeah that thing alright
good good to know alright one last note
here if you're reading this letter then
most likely I'm already dead I hear them
I hear these heart-rending cries
something invisible beyond human
perception blah blah blah crept out of
no are useless barricade who's his
roomie may be alive others are dead I'm
still here in the archives waiting for
their fate what's use of barricades and
locks as you sing certainly after Menace
power and may well be able to walk
through walls
dammit okay so anyway that's all the
time I have for this part there's been
something in my eye for a while I don't
know what I'm gonna get it out but thank
you all so much for watching click the
annotation for more videos that I've
done and as always I will see you in the
next video
[Music]
[Music]
yeah your grammar
I can bear